the world today has many problems and
they're all very complicated and
interconnected
and difficult
but there is something we can do
i believe
that girls education is the closest
thing we have to a silver bullet
to help solve some of the world's most
difficult problems
but you don't have to take my word for
it
the world bank says
that girls education is one of the best
investments that a country can make it
helps to positively impact nine of the
17 sustainable development goals
everything from health nutrition
employment all of these are positively
impacted when girls are educated
additionally
climate scientists have recently rated
girls education at number six out of 80
actions to reverse global warming
at number six it's rated higher than
solar panels and electric cars
and that's because when girls are
educated
they have smaller families and the
resulting reduction in population
reduces carbon emissions significantly
but more than that you know it's a
problem we have to solve once
because an educated mother
is more than twice as likely to educate
her children
which means that by doing it once we can
close the gender and literacy gap
forever
i work in india
which has made incredible progress in
bringing elementary education for all
however we still have four million out
of school girls one of the highest in
the world
and girls are out of school because of
obviously poverty
social cultural factors but there's also
this underlying factor of mindset
i have met a girl whose name was
naraznath
naraz means angry
and when i asked her why is your name
angry she said
because everybody was so angry when a
girl was born
another girl called antimbala which
means the last girl
because everybody hoped that would be
the last girl to be born
a girl called archuki
it means somebody who has arrived not
wanted but arrived
and it is this mindset
that keeps girls from school or
completing their education
it's this belief that a goat is an asset
and a girl is a liability
my organization educate girls works to
change this and we work in some of the
most difficult rural remote and tribal
villages
and how do we do it
we first and foremost find
young passionate educated youth from the
same villages
and both men and women
and we call them team balika balika just
means the girl child so this is a team
that we're creating for the girl child
and so once we recruit our community
volunteers we train them we mentor them
we handhold them
um that's when our work starts and the
first piece we do is about identifying
every single girl who's not going to
school
but the way we do it is a little
different and high-tech at least in my
view
each of our frontline staff have a
smartphone it has its own educate girls
app and this app has everything that our
team needs it has
digital maps um of where they're going
to be conducting the survey it has a
survey in it all the questions little
guides on how best to conduct the survey
so that the data that comes to us is in
real time and is of good quality
so armed with this our teams and our
volunteers go door to door to every
single household to find every single
girl who may either be never enrolled or
dropped out of school
and because we have this data and
technology piece very quickly we can
figure out who the girls are and where
they are because each of our villages
are geotagged and we can actually build
that information out very very quickly
and so once we know where the girls are
we actually start the process of
bringing them back into school
and that actually is just our community
mobilization process it starts with
village meetings neighborhood meetings
and as you see individual counseling of
parents and families to be able to bring
the girls back into school and this can
take anything from a few weeks
to a few months
and once we bring the girls into the
school system we also work with the
schools to make sure that schools have
all the basic infrastructure so that the
girls will be able to stay and this
would include
a separate toilet for girls drinking
water
things that will help them to be
retained
but
all of this would be useless if our
children weren't learning so we actually
run a learning program
and this is a supplementary learning
program and it's very very very
important
because most of our children are first
generation learners
that means there's nobody at home to
help them with homework there's nobody
who can support their education their
parents can't read and write so it's
really really key that we do the support
of of the learning in the classrooms
so this is essentially our model in
terms of finding bringing the girls in
making sure that they're staying and
learning and we know that our model
works
and we know this because
a most recent randomized control
evaluation confirms its efficacy
our evaluator found that over a three
year period
educate girls was able to bring back 92
percent of all out of school girls back
into
school and in terms of learning our
children's learning went up
significantly as compared to control
schools so much so that it was
like an additional year of schooling for
the average student
and that's enormous when you think about
a tribal child who's entering the school
system for the first time
so here we have we have a model that
works we know uh it's scalable because
we're already functioning at 13 000
villages we know it's smart because of
the use of data and technology
we know that it's sustainable and
systemic because we work in partnership
with the community it's actually led by
the community
and we work in partnership with the
government so there's no creation of a
parallel delivery system
and so because we have this innovative
partnership with the community with the
government this smart model
we have this big audacious dream today
and that is to solve a full 40 percent
of the problem of out-of-school girls in
india in the next five years
and you're thinking that's a little
you know how how am i even thinking
about doing that because india's not a
small place it's a huge country
um it's a country of over a billion
people
we have
650 000 villages
how is it that i'm standing here saying
that one small organization is going to
solve a full 40 percent of the problem
and that's because we have a key inside
and that is because of our entire
approach with data and with technology
that five percent of villages in india
have 40 percent of the out-of-school
girls
and this is a big big piece of the
puzzle which means i don't have to work
across the entire country i have to work
in those five percent of the villages
about 35 000 villages to actually be
able to solve a large piece of the
problem
and that's really key because these
villages
not only have high burden of out of
school girls but also a lot of related
indicators right like malnutrition
stunting
poverty infant mortality child marriage
so by working and focusing here you can
actually create a large multiplier
effect across all of these indicators
and it would mean that we would be able
to bring back 1.6 million girls back
into school
i have to say i have been doing this for
over a decade and i have never met a
girl
who said to me
you know i want to stay at home i want
to graze the cattle i want to look after
the siblings
i want to be a child bride every single
girl i meet wants to go to school
and that's what we really want to do we
want to be able to fulfill those 1.6
million dreams
and it doesn't take much to find and
enroll a girl with our model is about
twenty dollars
to make sure that she's learning and
providing a learning program it's
another forty dollars
but today is the time to do it because
she is truly the biggest asset we have
i am safina hussein and i educate girls
thank you